en espagne il est désormais interdit de
fumer dans la rue c'est la distance
sociale de deux mètres ne peut pas être
respecté cette mesure s'appliquait
auparavant en galice mais elle est
désormais commune tout le pays
le ministre de la santé espagnole
salvadori la a et danser également
d'autres restrictions les boîtes de nuit
bars nocturnes et celle de concerts
doivent fermer leurs portes
cette mesure s'appliquait depuis le 24
juillet en catalogne mais elle est
désormais valable dans toute l'espagne
alors de leur côté les bars et
restaurants devront fermer leurs portes
à une heure du matin maximum et ils ne
peuvent plus accepter de nouveaux
clients
après minuit ils n'ont pas non plus le
droit d'accepter les tables de plus de
10 personnes
l'espagne a lui aussi annoncé des
nouveautés concernant les tests pcr
ils seront automatiquement effectuée
dans tous les nouveaux foyers de
contagion
ça peut être des centres sanitaires
centre éducatif mais aussi les quartiers
de l'espagne alors la surveillance
policière va être augmentée pour veiller
au respect de ces mesures
du côté des espagnols ils sont partagés
certains ne comprennent pas pourquoi pas
une fermeture plutôt permettra d'éviter
la propagation du virus
mais pour d'autres il s'agit de bonnes
mesures si ça peut justement freiner
l'épidémie